[Applause]
and finally new rule when you're rioting
against donald trump and he loses
stop
this month radicals in portland and
seattle took to the streets in a protest
against the president
who for far too long has presided over
corruption and criminal behavior
joe biden that's right joe was president
for one day
when protesters went to town on
buildings storefronts garbage cans
and of course they broke windows at
starbucks because
well it's like they say in that
insurance commercial it's what you do
you know i understand the impetus for
street fighting at
times and done peacefully it can move
the needle
on how the public sees an issue
important
but while i'm sure it's fun to cosplay v
for vendetta every night let's be clear
as a means of actually affecting change
it's right up there with holding your
breath till you get a pony
and now that normality is back
and there's at least a chance that
government can function again
we need to be reminded of something
really important
that making progress real progress that
actually changes the lives of real
people
comes mainly from dull patient plotters
who put in their ten thousand hours
mastering the details of public service
it comes from people trapped in tiny
rooms at three a.m
with stale pizza and cold coffee
crafting laws
line by line that few will ever read or
thank them for
i know it's not the sexy answer but
change
comes from people who look like this
what if i told you there was a single
member of congress who brought the
tobacco industry to its knees
paved the way for less expensive generic
drugs
expanded medicaid to include pregnant
women and children
put the teeth into the clean air and
safe water drinking acts
and wrote most of obamacare you probably
wouldn't know who it was
even though i just showed you his
picture
[Applause]
you thought that was your pharmacist
[Laughter]
no that's henry waxman you always hear
things like the insurance companies
wrote obamacare well sure they had their
input but no most of it was written by
henry waxman
and not just the affordable care act
nursing home reform
food safety reform aids research
basically
if you ate it drank it breathed it or
[ __ ] it and it didn't kill you
you have waxman to thank
when it came to actually making people
healthier between 1975 and 2015.
he did everything but get the cigarettes
out of firing squads
as one top republican said 50 percent of
the social safety net was created by
henry waxman when no one was looking
and that's the thing about being a
workhorse instead of a show horse
no one's looking waxman never went on
the sunday talk shows he didn't do tv at
all
the camera didn't love him and the
feeling was mutual
we uh we asked him once to do our show
and he said no i'm too busy he didn't
even put himself on the cover of his own
book
he could have published relentless
taking back america from the takers who
took it
but that wasn't his style his style was
getting stuff
done liberals to paraphrase ted kennedy
see wrong and try to write it see
suffering and try to heal it
see war and try to stop it we see this
i want it to become this but how does
that actually happen
it's easy to spray paint [ __ ] you on a
federal building
it's a little harder to work inside
and actually make [ __ ] happen
this this lady just wants someone in the
government to take responsibility and
clean up that toxic waste dump
that's so close to where she lives who
actually gets that done
baldy over here
i i hate to have to put it this way
but mostly you have to make republicans
do the right thing
i'm sorry to have to say that you do
and this guy doesn't do that this guy
has
people
people don't live in the world of
political philosophies and
endless intersectional theorizing they
live in the world
of is there going to be a hot lunch at
school
no lead in the toys getting minimum wage
and helping the victims of human
trafficking
john kerry always looks tired because
things like the
iran nuclear deal or the paris accords
don't just plan themselves the irony of
hillary clinton being done in by her
emails was that if you actually read
them they'd bore you to tears because
that's what a policy wong meticulously
doing her job
looks like
john kerry hillary barney frank john
lewis
nancy pelosi obama this is the time for
people like that
the wonks who never satisfy the radicals
but know how to actually make progress
as opposed to doing progressive theater
it's not the screamers and the tweeters
it's the worker bees with the name tags
and the binders
they deserve an award and so tonight i
am introducing in honor of our first
recipient henry waxman
the baldi awards
and the baldi each year will go to the
most waxman-like congress person
and hopefully it will become the most
coveted award a politician can earn
we need to bring un sexy back
congratulations henry this is for you
and all the unheralded grinders who
pushed the boulders up history's hill
all right that's our show i want to
thank van jones james bo
brett weinstein and heather heing we'll
see you next week thank you folks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you bill for this award i'm
honored to be the first recipient of the
baldi award i know there'll be other
baldies that will follow me who will
also be deserving but i've got to get
back to work
there's a lot of work to do so thank you
very much
you